اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه انها نفذت هجوما
على مستودعي اسلحه ونفط للجيش الروسي في
شبه جزيره القرم وكان حاكم القرم الموالي
لروسيا قد اكد وقوع الهجوم ما تسبب بوقوع
انفجارات في المستودع وقال المسؤول الروسي
ان القصف لم يسفر عن وقوع عصابات وانه جرى
اجلاء جميع السكان من المناطق المتاخمه
للمستودع وقد اعلنت استئناف العمل في سكه
القطارات بالقرم بعد تعليقه مرتين وفي
الوقت نفسه قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
اوكرانيا هاجمت مجموعه من الصحفيين ماده
لمقتل احدهم واصابه اخرين في
مقابلات مع الجزيره اكد المتحدث باسم
البحريه الاوكرانيه استهداف مستودع روسيا
للذخيره والوقود في شبه جزيره القرم
بالنسبه
للضربات على المنطقه
المحرمه فكنا قد ضربنا
واستهدفنا
مستودعا للذخيره
ومستودعات للوقود على الاراضي القرميه
كما قالت المتحدثه باسم القياده عمليات
الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني التاليه كان
قصف خطوط امداد القوات الروسيه سوف يستمر
واشارت الى ان بلادها التزمت بالتحذير
الذي اطلقته سابقا بان موسم الانفجارات في
شبه جزيره القرم حان وقت وحان وقته وفق
تعبيرها
ان موسم الانفجارات في شبه جزيره القرم
قدحان ونحن نلتزم بكلمتنا ان تقدم قواتنا
لا يتم فقط على طول الجبهه بل هو ايضا
تحرك في العمق الخلفي للعدو الذي يشعر
حاليا بالقلق واستهداف العمق هو وسيله
لحرمان العدو من امكانياته اللوجيستيه ومن
الواضح انه بات يعاني من ضعف القدره
اللوجيسيه على ارسال المعدات العسكريه او
سحبها مستمرون بعمليه القصف الصاروخي
وسنضرب عمق العدو حيث يحتفظ بمخزونه
الاستراتيجي
هذا وقال نيكولاي
عضو مجلس الدومان الروسي للجزيره انه هجوم
اوكرانيا على جسر القرم نقض لقواعد الحرب
وان موسكو ستحقق فيه وستعاقب المسؤولين عن
القرم ليست هدفا عسكريا والكل يعلم هذا
انها منطقه سياحيه حيث يسكن المدنيون وحسب
اما هجوم اوكرانيا على القرم وجسر القرم
فهو نقد لقواعد الحرب وسنقوم بالتحقيق في
هذا الامر وسنعاقب المسؤولين عنه حتى
بالتصفيه الشخصيه
دخل في الشمال الاطلسيا ما وصفها بمحاولته
موسكو واستخدام الغذائي سلاحه وخلال اتصال
مع الرئيس الاوكراني اكد ستولتنبرغ على
وقوف الحلف مع اوكرانيا طالما تتطلب الامر
ذلك واشار الى انها اقرب الى النيتو منها
في اي وقت مضى حسب تعبيره اما الرئيس
الاوكراني فقال انه حدد مع الامين العام
للنيت هو الاولويه والخطوات المستقبليه
اللازمه لفتح ممر للحبوب في البحر الاسود
وتشغيله بشكل مستدى
معنا من كيف مراسله الجزيره عمر الحاج هذا
الاتصال فيه تحدث عن الحبوب تحديدا وما
قاله الرئيس الاوكراني ما هي تفاصيل كيف
سيتوفر هذا الممر في ظل تهديد روسيا
باستهداف كل السفن الواصله الى اوكرانيا
نعم زي لفهم هذا لابد ان نعود الى تصريحات
الاوكرانيه الاولى التي جاءت بعيده اعلان
روسيا ايقافها العمل بهذه الاتفاقيه
اوكرانيا حينها قدمت نوعا من البديل عن
هذه الاتفاقيه بتخصيصها لممرات اقرب الى
السواحل البلغاريه تنطلق كما العاده من
ميناء اوديسا ولكن على ان تكون الرقابه
التركيه فقط هي المسؤوله عن تحرك هذه
السفن كما ان بعض الدول ايضا من دول شرق
اوروبا كرواتيا على سبيل المثال ودول اخرى
قالت ان هناك طريقا قد يكون اطول واصعب
وهو عن طريق
ارسال هذه الشحنات عن طريق البر ايضا
اوكرانيا قالت انها بامكانها توفير كل كل
ما يلزم لهذا الطريق البديل سواء من منشات
ومرافق وايضا موانع وحتى سفن وانها توصلت
الى اتفاقات اوليه مع شركات الشحن لاتمام
هذا الاتفاق ولكن كما نعلم الرد الروسي
جاء سريعا بتهديده استهداف كل هذه السفن
في حال اقدمت منفرده على الاستمرار في هذه
الاتفاقيه التي كما ذكرنا رفضت روسيا
تجديدها ايضا في هذا الاتصال جاء حديث عن
اتفاقيات التي وقعت وقعت بين روسيا بين
اوكرانيا وبين
النيتو في بات يعرف بصيغه الناتو اوكرانيا
حول عمليه الانضمام التي تسعى اليها
اوكرانيا انضمام لحلف شمال الاطلسي اضافه
الى المساعدات التي تقدم الى اوكرانيا
ايضا هذا الاتصال زين لا بد من قراءته ضمن
التطورات الاخيره في البحر الاسود من
الاستهداف والاستهداف المضاد من قبل
اوكرانيا للسفن الروسيه وحتى القواعد
الروسيه سواء في شبه جزيره القرم او حتى
جسر القرم النقطه الحساسه بالنسبه بالنسبه
لروسيا وارتفاع التوتر في البحر الاسود
بعد تهديد اوكرانيين مماثل للسفن المدنيه
التي تحاول نقل الحبوب الروسيه سواء من
مواليها في البحر الاسود او سواء من
الموانئ التي تسيطر عليها روسيا سواء في
بردياسكو ايضا في مدينه ميلتو على بحري
ازوف عند بحر ازوف شكرا جزيلا لك عمر
الحاج من